la mort de l'acteur patrick dewaere cet
après midi à paris s'agirait d'un
suicide
le séminaire des socialistes à maisons
laffitte le ps et le gouvernement
redéfinissent leur rapport l'amiral
sanguinetti exclus du parti
la guerre entre l'iran et l'irak terran
reconnaît une vigoureuse pour repenser
irakienne enfin polémique entre paris et
washington qui faisait état d'un accord
secret franco soviétique il ya deux ans
les français avec une catégorie qu mans
bien messieurs bonsoir c'est un homme en
pleine gloire en pleine jeunesse est en
pleine ascension qui était découvert
inanimé cet après midi à son domicile à
paris patrick dewaere 35 ans était
réclamée par tous les réalisateurs il
devait tourner d'ailleurs un nouveau
film avec claude lelouch dès lundi c'est
la raison pour laquelle on a eu du mal à
imaginer qu'il se soit vraiment suicidé
comme tout semble le prouver
et d'abord la présence d'un fusil à ses
côtés patrick dewaere venait déjeuner
avec son futur metteur en scène il avait
l'air en pleine forme on l'attendait
dans l'après midi dans la salle de boxe
de marcel cerdan le fils du grand boxeur
dont il devait d'ailleurs retracé la
carrière et les amours avec edith piaf
il s'entraîner quotidiennement vue de ce
film c'est son domestique qui a
découvert son corps en début
d'après-midi et alerter une voisine chez
tous ses proches
donc la stupéfaction et une immense
tristesse patrick dewaere et est en
train de devenir l'un des très grandes
ce métier
là
aulas
de marche funèbre pour patrick une
musique trop gay incongrue qui lui
ressemble
il riait avec de grands yeux tristes et
il jouait sa vie comme un adulte qui
aurait terriblement regretté l'enfance
et les taloches il avait voulu quitter
le spectacle il avait débuté à six ans
pour faire de la musique mais par le
biais du café théâtre il y était revenu
inquiet de ses succès ils cherchaient
dans les rôles de marginaux de paumés de
farfelu qu'on lui proposait des reflets
de lui même l'écran le montrait temps du
sauvage déchiré facilement comme il
était dans la vie dans série noire ou
hôtel des amériques amant plein
d'angoissé de rave dans préparez vos
mouchoirs ou les valseuses voyez au
coeur tendre dans un mauvais fils car
sont rejetées par les siens et tenter
par la drogue
patrick dewaere à 35 ans a fait sa plus
grosse bêtise ans qui est un allemand du
1000m et cherchait ce qui fait mal
l'amour par exemple c'est ce qui
repousse le plus que ce que ce ce qui
fait le plus mal
dans la mise en oeuvre pleine de jouets
bertrand blier c'est vous qui avez
révélé patrick dewaere au grand public
quand vous l'avez choisie pour jouer
dans les valseuses
qu'est ce qui vous avait plus en lui
pourquoi l'avez vous choisi c'est plus
vous savez je suis tellement sous le
choc je veux ça m'est difficile de
parler de cinéma et j'ai l'impression de
l'heure pour moi patrick aujourd'hui
c'est pas c'est pas un acteur c'est en
face quelqu'un de ma famille qui vient
de 10 par an c'est tout et comment
expliquez-vous ce jet c'est un jeu est
complet jamais expliqué je crois que des
gens qui qui porte sa en eux et ils
d'autres postes n'a rien à voir avec le
problème de l'existence
je les ai vus hier soir il est venu chez
moi alors bavarder
j'étais loin de m'attendre ce genre de
surprise c'est pas du tout il ne vous
avais pas du tout parlé non il était ma
meuse assez en forme
ofi oui il est arrivé chez moi il
sortait son entraînement de boxe pour le
film de lelouch maintenant d'être l'eau
minérale
il était en forme et est content il y
avait des projets
il cherche
je n'arrive pas à réaliser encore will
dernier film de patrick dewaere le
paradis pour tous des lingettes sua doit
sortir fin août c'est je crois que sa
silhouette de paume et de voyous fragile
manquera au cinéma français sans
transition
l'actualité est ainsi faite nous allons
parler politique avec ce séminaire
socialiste de maisons laffitte qui toute
la journée a réuni au château les
principaux dirigeants du parti et les
membres socialistes du gouvernement au
premier rang desquels bien sûr pierre
moure loin des dates grâce d'il ya un an
dans une conjoncture économique et
politique beaucoup plus difficile
les deux délégations avaient beaucoup de
choses à dire mais loin des regards et
des oreilles indiscrètes paul amar
images étonnantes difficile au premier
coup d'oeil de reconnaître les ministres
des autres la hiérarchie oublier
certaines excellence en bras de chemise
pas de protocole pas de place réservée
aux ministres d'état images révélatrices
les hommes du président ministres
dirigeants du parti du député tenait à
montrer qu'il travaillait dans la plus
parfaite harmonie leur intention prouver
à la presse que les relations
tumultueuses illustré par de nombreux
incidents aux reproches réciproques et
bien ses relations la sont oubliées les
clapotis comme disait jean poperen c'est
fini place désormais à la concertation
entre les hommes qui sont tous
socialistes mais qui d'après lionel
jospin ne se rencontraient pas assez
souvent
il était important que ces hommes et ces
femmes qui sont dans des fonctions
différentes mais qui sont tous
socialistes et bien puisse parler
ensemble parler et se parler et donc au
fond cette réflexion collective
elle est l'objectif même de cette
rencontre réflexion collective sur les
moyennes de lutter contre la crise très
grave à leur avis dramatique même et les
moyens de réussir le changement
réflexions menées toute la journée par 5
commission mixte composée de ministres
et de membres du parti sur la situation
économique et sociale sur la situation
internationale les libertés et les
problèmes de société
mes réflexions seulement dans l'esprit
de lionel jospin il n'était pas question
aujourd'hui de prendre des décisions
même si le parti souhaitait jouer un
rôle plus actif
le rôle du parti dans cette affaire
lequel soutient le gouvernement parce
que si les socialistes ne soutenait pas
l'enfant politiques qu'ils là
soutiendraient et qui en même temps de
ne pas perdre son rôle de stimulant et
doit commencer à travailler sur des
questions que le gouvernement confirmé
dans la gestion quotidienne ne peut pas
peut-être travailler suffisamment une
précision intéressante cet événement
pouvait en effet donner l'impression
aujourd'hui que le parti socialiste
entend des élaboré lui aussi la
politique de la france et revenir même
sans le vouloir au temps de la quatrième
république au temps du régime des partis
nous confusion que lionel jospin a voulu
dissiper même si ce séminaire sera
suivie d'autres rencontres du même type
sans doute eu à l'automne est bien le
parti socialiste ne se substituera pas
au gouvernement mais les propos de son
premier secrétaire ont tout de même
montré que les membres du parti
socialiste entend n'est joué un rôle
plus actif ni godillots ni censeurs mais
aussi et surtout acteur c'est peut-être
l'esprit de la vème république qui a
changé dans une certaine mesure
aujourd'hui à maisons laffitte et en
marge de ce séminaire le bureau exécutif
du ps ce matin a exclu les responsables
socialistes corps ce dissident cela
concerne au premier chef
il est reconnu l'amiral sanguine et il
s'agit de responsables socialistes qui
avait décidé de se présenter contre la
liste
officielle du ps aux élections
régionales du 8 août en corse
eh bien ces responsables se sont mis
hors du en dehors du parti de même a
déclaré le ps dans caméral sanguinetti
exclu du parti socialiste
autre sommet celui d'hier à l'hôtel
matignon le premier ministre avait
recommandé aux partenaires sociaux
d'essayer de s'écarter du système
d'indexation des salaires sur les prix
ce qui évidemment n'a pas fait plaisir à
grand monde c'était attendu
jean claude renaud fait lé point du
dispositif gouvernemental a maintenant
trois mois et demi de la sortie de ce
blocage des prix et des salles
financement de l'assurance chômage
premier point les fonctionnaires
cotiseront à partir du 1er novembre les
syndicats grogne une fois encore
distille ce sont les salariés qui payent
deuxième point parmi les non salariés
seuls les professions libérales
cotiseront pour les chômeurs
commerçants artisans et agriculteurs ne
cotiseront pas pourquoi le gouvernement
estime que le commerce contribue déjà la
solidarité avec le 1% supplémentaire de
tva qu'il ne répercute pas sur les prix
de vente
même chose pour les agriculteurs qui
n'ont pas eu droit à une dévaluation du
franc vers aulas pour l'assurance
chômage
deuxième problème soulevé hier à
matignon
comment sortir en douceur du blocage des
prix à des salles est la pierre moreau a
été moins précis mais il a donné les
consignes du gouverneur premièrement le
blocage sera suivie de 14 mois d'efforts
et de discipline pour éviter tout
dérapage
deuxièmement pour les salaires on
devrait donc négociés branche par
branche dès la rentrée mais le premier
ministre souhaite que les os x limité en
partant du principe que l'inflation sera
ralentie troisièmement pour les prix des
accords de modération devront être
signés avec les commerçants et les
prestataires de services parmi les
catégories les plus revendicative les
agriculteurs françois guillaume le
président de la fnsea a dit tout à
l'heure à privas qu'il redoutait les
actions incontrôlées de paysans qui
pourrait dégénérer en violences pour un
certain nombre d'entre eux un problème
supplémentaire la sécheresse il y a deux
heures le ministère de l'agriculture
faisait savoir que la sécheresse
actuelle n'avait rien de comparable avec
celle de l'été 76 deux départements sont
essentiellement touchées des ministères
la lozère
et la haute-loire mais d'autres tel
l'aveyron éleva souhaite être déclarée
zone sinistrée
c'est du var précisément que reviennent
jean-louis calmejane et michel et lykov
le vin où il n'a pas plu depuis plus
d'un mois ci au centre de la
météorologie nationale du var on a fait
la constatation suivante
de janvier à juin de cette année il est
tombé en pluie l'équivalent de ce
plusieurs mètres et demi
or dans cette même période la quantité
de pluie normal qui aurait dû tomber
pendant donc ces six mois aurait dû
remplir normalement ces cinq pluviomètre
réunis autour de moi c'est la
constatation donc d'une sécheresse
importante qui est aggravée par le fait
que ce déficit en eau on le constate ici
depuis deux ans c'est une sécheresse
grave donc qui n'est pas sans
conséquences pour l'agriculture
à commencer par l'arrière pays varois
ici on termine de moissonner on y fait
de l'élevage de moutons surtout et de la
vigne pour la vigne on espère encore les
pluies d'orage traditionnel de fin
juillet mais pour les céréales les
moissons seront très faibles
cette année nous avons eu nos efforts
très déficitaire vous voyez d'ailleurs
la hauteur de cet orge et stanick nous
aurions à peine un genou alors qu'en
temps normal
j'arrive au moyen âge normalement nous
avons la possibilité de récolter 45 à 50
quintaux ha cette année péniblement nous
arriverons à tour 18 avec les éleveurs
n'ont pu faire qu'une coupe de fourrage
au printemps et encore la récolte était
faible
après l'herbe n'a plus repoussé elle a
grillé et là où sont passés les moutons
ils ont constaté le même phénomène
ce qui va leur poser des problèmes pour
nourrir leurs bêtes à l'automne les
éleveurs auront la possibilité soit
d'acheter des forages ne prennent pas
soin de vendre une partie de leurs
propos je prends ce fort que ce sera là
ce que nous rencontrons le plus souvent
sur la côte varoise
on y produit surtout des fruits des
légumes et des fleurs coupées
ici le déficit en eau est un peu moins
important que dans l'arrière-pays
mais la sécheresse a été amplifiée par
un vent très chaud type sirocco qui a
brûlé de nombreuses récoltes comme vous
pouvez le constater il a pris un coup de
soleil
si on peut dire un coup de chaleur et vu
que la température était tellement élevé
le mercredi 17 7 juillet et c'était un
genre de sirocco et kiev qui a fait
brûler tous les maux l'enquêté exposé au
soleil et ça devient invendables et à
port la forêt survenu tard après ça
arrive à pourrir
est ce que vous allez faire maintenant
maintenant il fait c'est la récolte est
pratiquement perdu et on va se faire
tout son possible pour labourer le plus
possible et repeintes et autres choses
la seule chose qui nous reste à qui nous
reste à faire c'est le cas pour de
nombreux producteurs de tomates comme
celui ci qui a dû enfuir ces trois
hectares après avoir sauvé un quart de
sa production
les tomates qui reste au sol sont brûlés
et impropre à la consommation
et pourtant de nombreux maraîchers ont
la possibilité d'irriguer ils ne s'en
privent pas avec notamment le réseau
d'irrigation du canal de provence
mais malgré cette irrigation le coup de
chaleur du 7 juillet à brûler de
nombreuses productions certaines
communes du var sont depuis quelques
jours alimentées en eau potable par les
pompiers
des pompiers qui ont déjà beaucoup à
faire pour éteindre des nombreux
incendies de forêt qui se sont déclarés
plutôt que prévu cette année
des incendies qui comme ici le fameux 7
juillet ont détruit bon nombre
d'hectares de forêt sur les collines de
la ville d'hyères
alain gillot-pétré qui n'a pas pris de
coup de chaleur nous dira enfin le
journal ce à quoi nous devons nous
attendre pour la fin de la semaine
toujours à destination de l'agriculteur
cette information qui nous vient de la
cour européenne de justice qui a décidé
de la grande bretagne devait ouvrir ses
frontières aux volailles européennes et
que les mesures qu'elle avait pris dans
ce sens contraire et est il légal
premier titre de notre chapitre
étrangers ce soir la guerre iran irak
ils s'en vont en effet que tu es en
rencontres de la part des troupes de
bagdad une résistance plus forte que
prévu aidé iranienne on faisait des
passes et après midi d'une vaste
contre-offensive irakienne et ce alors
que des manifestations de soutien se
multiplient à téhéran et comme ici sur
ces images à bagdad
jean-marc il ose longue vie au président
seul un but cinq cette manifestation
hier dans les rues de bagdad
une manière pour la télévision d'état
irakienne de montrer à l'étranger qu'ici
l'appel aux soulèvements lancée par
l'ayatollah khomeiny ne rencontre pas de
sympathie pour l'irak
les mollahs iraniens tentent d'exécuter
actuellement sur son territoire un plan
conçu par israël et les états unis
paradoxe aujourd'hui à téhéran une
manifestation de soutien à l'armée
accuse l'irak de bénéficier des mêmes
complicités étrangères
ces véhicules iranien en feu à l'est de
basra images irakienne toujours l'irak
affirme depuis hier soir avoir bouter
l'envahisseur iranien hors de ses
frontières
ce qui semble certain c'est que depuis
hier soir
la contre-offensive irakienne a pris de
l'ampleur teheran le laisse entendre
très clairement mais déclare avoir
repoussé les forces de bagdad
non seulement dans le sud de la
frontière mais aussi dans une localité
située à 600 km au nord du front
principal celui de bassorah et puis
l'aviation irakienne a poursuivi ses
attaques
aujourd'hui ramadân ville iranienne de
200000 habitants a été bombardé à deux
reprises ce matin 73 morts plusieurs
centaines de blessés selon les iraniens
dans une guerre où les populations
civiles semblent bien menacée par
l'escaladé du conflit
autres zones brûlante au proche-orient
le liban
on a appris aujourd'hui la mort d'un
casques bleus français le 8 janvier le 8
juillet dernier par dont joël david qui
appartenait au 17e régiment de génie
parachutiste basé à montauban il avait
26 ans sur le plan diplomatique la
france a fait savoir la syrie a fait
savoir qu'elle n'accepterait pas de
recevoir les combattants palestiniens
sur son territoire car cela équivaudrait
a déclaré le ministre syrien des
affaires étrangères a liquidé la
révolution et la cause palestinienne à
beyrouth nous rejoignons patricia cost
salée car c'est maintenant et faire de
la palestine un quartier
particulièrement exposées se trouve
toujours la permanence de l'ump qui n'a
pas voulu symboliquement se replier
président de l'ol nous a déclaré cet
après-midi les syriens ne veulent pas
nous
je les comprends très bien alors quand
je ferais la même chose
le problème n'est pas le leader des
palestiniens aurait dit au premier
ministre libanais il avait pas croire
aussi dessiné en a l'air ton petit
peuple de beyrouth s'installe pour un
logiciel des manifestations tout à
l'heure à beyrouth ouest à la sortie des
mosquées manifestations hostiles à
israël organisée par des fidèles
musulmans
manifestations également à jérusalem est
quelques vingt mille palestiniens ont
protesté aux abords de l'esplanade des
mosquées est la fae omar contre
l'offensive israélienne ou libre et puis
avec maurice werther maintenant les
premières images d'un camp de
prisonniers palestiniens
capturé par l'armée israélienne ce camp
de toile filmé par la télévision
américaine avec l'assentiment des
autorités israéliennes servira à
l'internement des cinq six mille
prisonniers palestiniens capturé par
l'armée isrélienne désiré lien
reconnaissent que parmi ces prisonniers
de guerre il doit y avoir au nombre de
civils palestiniens arrêtés plus ou
moins par essence ce camp est situé à
une quinzaine de kilomètres au nord de
la frontière entre israël et le liban
c'est à dire en territoire libanais
jusqu'à présent les israéliens
contrairement aux conventions
internationales n'ont pas autoriser la
croix rouge à rendre visite au
prisonnier
mais il assure que dès dimanche
l'organisation humanitaire pourra
remplir sa mission
il faut dire que josem ne considère pas
ces prisonniers comme des prisonniers de
guerre mais de droit commun donc non
concernés par la convention de genève
une polémique est clair la nuit dernière
entre washington et paris polémique déjà
apparemment éteintes les américains
accusaient les français d'avoir conclu
un accord secret avec des soviétiques il
y a deux ans accord qui portait sur
l'octroi de crédits à moscou le haut
fonctionnaire du pentagone qui avait
lancé l'information est resté de nîmes
et le démenti français a été cinglant
aussi bien la part du quai d'orsay que
de celui du cabinet de valérie giscard
d'estaing qui était à l'époque aux
affaires le commentaire de paulin les
démentis formels de la signature de cet
accord secret franco soviétique sont
venues de deux horizons politiques
radicalement différents le premier de la
part de l'actuel gouvernement français
qui repousse fermement les accusations
américaines
on les trouve je cite affligeante
inexact de ziem démenti encore de
l'entourage même de valéry giscard
d'estaing qui refuse également les
propos tenus par ce haut fonctionnaire
du pentagone
des propos dit-on fantaisistes et
irresponsable pendant que quand bien
même cet accord secret existerait un
pays comme la france a parfaitement le
droit de signer de tels accords avec des
clauses secrètes ne serait ce ne serait
ce que pour se protéger de la
concurrence étrangère ces contrats qui
sont purement économiques et commerciaux
et qui ne concerne pas les problèmes de
défense militaire et d'alliances
alors au delà de cette querelle franco
américaine il s'agit encore d'une
nouvelle dégradation des relations entre
paris et washington consécutive au
sommet de versailles les etats unis qui
ce monde décidément intransigeant avec
les européens et la france notamment
quand il s'agit de commerce avec l'union
soviétique alors que washington il faut
bien le rappeler continue d'envoyer
pratiquement tous les mois des quantités
tout à fait considérable de blé en
direction l'union soviétique donc dans
cette affaire il semble bien qu'il y ait
deux poids et deux mesures
pologne remaniement du bureau politique
et du secrétariat du parti au pouvoir un
remaniement qui touche à la fois les
plus modérés et les plus durs du parti
moon est bien le révérend moon ce
condamné à 18 mois de prison pour fraude
fiscale
à new york le dollar à 6 francs 14 6
francs 94 en cette fin de semaine sur le
marché parisien le franc français plutôt
faible petite diminution du nombre des
victimes d'accidents de la route en ile
de france elle est dernière une tendance
qui n'est pas confirmée par tous mais
que le gouvernement souhaite accélérer
savait qu'en début de semaine à sa
nombre de mesures ont été prises pour y
parvenir
parmi lesquels la généralisation du pare
brise en verre en verre feuilleté alors
est ce la plus efficace en tout cas la
plus urgente
la réponse de martine à la radio quelle
que soit la cause et la gravité de
l'accident qu'il soit dans le véhicule
les percuter de l'extérieur un tiers des
accidentés de la route
heurte un pare brise on comprend donc la
préoccupation acharné des pouvoirs
publics et les constructeurs à vouloir
équiper les voitures de pare brise les
plus inoffensifs possible qu'ils
n'explosent pas un cas de choc qui ne
coupent pas qui n'abîme pas les yeux qui
ne fracture pas les crânes le verre
feuilleté avec sa feuille de plastique
intermédiaire l'emportent sur le verre
trempé moins cher mais qui peut
provoquer des lésions que l'on sait et
que l'on sait mesurer sur des mannequins
cependant des tests récents montrent que
si le verre feuilleté supérieur il ne
résout pas loin de là tous les problèmes
de ceux qui percute l'avant d'un
véhicule
en revanche une ceinture de sécurité
porte en permanence et vite ce journal
va se poser l'appareil
et si le pare-brise éclate il est
suffisamment long de la figure il est
suffisamment loin de la figure alors à
partir de là on peut dire que l'
avantage du pare brise feuilleté c'est
que en sécurité active c'est à dire par
exemple si vous recevez un caillou dans
votre pare brise il n'éclatera pas et
ceci peut être important effectivement
parce que le conducteur ne perdra pas le
contrôle de sa voiture qui fait de
l'éclatement de son pare brise
autre avantage peut-être du pare brise
feuilleté c'est que il lorsqu'il lit un
choc
il y a moins de poussière qui volent à
l'intérieur de l'habitacle dont
peut-être un peu moins de lésions
oculaires
alors en cas d'accident il y a deux
partenaires dans un véhicule et assedic
et à l'intérieur du véhicule et puis
l'autre
oui alors vis-à-vis de l'autre c'est à
dire vous voulez parler du motocycliste
ou du piéton eh bien je ne crois pas que
le brise feuilleté changera grand chose
pour le motocyclisme ce qui changera ses
qui porte son casque et à casque correct
pour le piéton
malheureusement il n'est pas protégé et
les problèmes sont aux autres et ne sont
pas uniquement ceux du pare brise mais
ceux des montants du pare brise et ce
peut-être de la manière dont il va
recevoir le choc c'est à dire l'appli
maison du capot de la voiture il ya des
recherches qui sont faites dans ce sens
actuellement et peut-être aussi la
vitesse des véhicules à la vitesse mais
c'est les mesures de base la ceinture de
sécurité
la limitation de vitesse à respecter
l'appuie tête aussi dans une certaine
mesure et en plus le grand problème en
france qui reste majeur c'est
l'alcoolémie au volant
donc le feuilleter ça vient loin
derrière donc le feuilleter je viens un
peu loin derrière je bras daniel
beaumont s'est livré à la justice daniel
beaumont vous savez c'est ce malfaiteur
qui s'était évadé par hélicoptère de la
prison de fleury mérogis il y a un an et
demi et bien il est revenu aujourd'hui
en france par avion en provenance de
madrid pour se livrer à la justice
il venait d'être remise en liberté en
espagne après avoir été arrêté à la
suite d'une fusillade qui l'a rendu
infirme à vie
et puis ce fait divers tout à fait
étonnant grande bretagne un père de six
enfants a passé huit ans
cachée sous le plancher de son salon
pour échapper à la justice ils avaient
été interrogés dans le cadre d'une
banale enquête sur un vol il s'était
fait un trou de 50 cm de profondeur sous
le parc est la maison seuls sa femme et
étoffant ses enfants n'en savait rien
ils ne l'ont pas reconnu lorsqu'il est
définitivement sorti de son trou il
avait perdu toutes ses dents et maigri
de près de 40 kg pas de poursuites pas
d' enquête il en a assez bavé on dit en
gros la justice et la police britannique
une polémique après la publication des
dix sept places à distribuer sur la
fréquence des radios libres parisienne
il y avait près de 150 demandeurs et
mais la plupart des radios ont été
invités à se regrouper mais on note déjà
plusieurs grands absents sur la liste
provisoire
rfm la station de patrick meyer ou bien
radio fréquence gaie la radio des
homosexuels qui toutes les deux proteste
le tour de france maintenant encore une
étape pour rien ou presque dans ce tour
on attendait pourtant beaucoup de
l'arrivée au sommet du plateau d' à
desbiens bernard i do i know a une fois
de plus une voyante est ici contrôlé la
course il ne termine que sixième de
l'étape mais consolide sa position de
leader en taux vainqueur de l'étape le
voici c'est le suisse béate breux un
coureur de 25 ans qui possède de
remarquables qualités de grimpeur et qui
ne manque pas d'ambition il a déclaré ce
soir être là pour gagner le tour de
france tandis tour de france
à la voile et tout va bien pour le
bateau le havre qui a tout gagné l'étape
d'hier le spi bleus et le spi l'air
venant maintenant terminée en musique
avec le fus tant chantée qui ouvrait
hier soir le festival d'aix en provence
un festival qui fête cette année ses 35
ans et qui s'affirme comme l'une des
plus importantes manifestations
musicales européennes
le soleil provençal et si brûlant c'est
ainsi que notre envoyé spécial george
bégoux ces réfugiés tout près des
fontaines de la bonne ville de sézanne
pour recueillir les premiers échos du
festival 80 heures les fontaines d'aix
ont beaucoup davantage d'abord elle
apporte la fraîcheur par ces temps de
canicule ensuite ce sont des bavarder
elle murmure que le montage de la flûte
enchantée qui marquait le début du
festival ne s'est pas fait sans mal
il a fallu remplacer une cantatrice mais
cela nous a donné l'occasion de
découvrir john recherche une jeune
anglaise de 24 ans qui chante le rôle de
pamina à ravir
oh
quand je vous disais que les fontaines
d'aix était très attaché au théâtre ici
sur cette place de dauphin dans quelques
jours sera créé un opéra de rossini le
turc en italie mais en attendant le
commencement des répétitions les
dauphins qui aime aussi la peinture vont
conseiller d'aller voir du côté du musée
granet une splendide exposition le paul
cézanne
une trentaine d'oeuvres essentielles
sont réunis qui témoigne de
l'attachement de sézanne au paysage
aixois qui le vit naître et mourir des
résonances moderne tir et d'instruments
d'origine antique c'est le secret de
silvio gualde a invité du centre
acanthes l'un des hauts lieux de la vie
musicale du festi sino gold à une classe
et cette place devient un très célèbre
puisque des percussionnistes viennent
vraiment de toute l'europe et même de
plus loin d'ailleurs pour travailler
avec silvio gualde à le répertoire
contemporain
que ce soit les oeuvres de xenakis de
stockhausen l'année en année le centre
acanthes accueille un grand créateur de
notre époque
et d'année en année nous avons reçu des
musiciens pour la première fois le
centre acanthes s'ouvre à une nouvelle
discipline qui est la danse et maurice
béjart fait travailler des stagiaires
qui sont venues du monde entier et qui
pendant deux semaines vont mieux
comprendre grâce à son enseignement ce
qu'est la danse et ce qu'est la danse
contemporaine mais il a d'autres
collaborateurs qui l'ont rejoint ici
notamment dans le domaine de la danse et
notamment pierre henry
qui a travaillé avec lui depuis très
longtemps et aussi les représentants du
groupe moudrak voudra qui est l'école
qu'il a fondée à bruxelles il y à une
seconde école à dakar c'est voudra
afrique et nous avons reçu cette année
des africains qui donne des cours de
percussions africaines et de danse
africaine aussi en collaboration avec
maurice béjart
en musique donc alain gillot-pétré et sa
pochette jaune bon signe oui oui
pochette jaune de deux soleils bientôt
il y aura la pochette rouge de de
chaleur car cela fait hélas le malheur
de beaucoup d'agriculteurs vous l'avez
vu tout à l'heure mais nous aurons vu
globalement pour les vacances est un
très très joli mois de juillet comme il
ya longtemps qu'on n'avait pas eu car le
beau temps revient avec une bouffée
l'anticyclone des açores qui va nous
dire bonjour demain sur la majeure
partie du pays beaucoup de brume le
matin et du soleil l'après midi sur le
sud est un ordi pyrénées-orientales aux
alpes du sud et à la corse le temps sera
passagèrement très nuageux avec quelques
orages mais là je ne crois pas que ce
soit suffisant pour empêcher la la
sécheresse de continuer car après il va
faire très beau j'ai beau lire tout à
l'heure sur le nord-est du pays quelques
passages nuageux aussi en cours de
journée pour dimanche lundi mardi et
peut-être même mercredi
c'est du beau temps sur tout le pays
après dissipation des brumes matinales
c'est reparti pour un tour de très beau
temps les températures pour demain sont
en hausse partout minimum 21 degrés à
brest maximum 32 soit la méditerranée
température moyenne sur l'ensemble de la
france 25 degrés et progressivement ça
va augmenter jusqu'à mardi jusqu'à
atteindre 35 à 38 degrés selon les
régions demain samedi 17 juillet trois
minutes de soleil en moins levé 6h07
kuchi 21h46 c'est la scène charlotte et
comme le disait mon compère laurent
broomhead l'année dernière à même époque
le même jour là même 5 en appétit voilà
c'est patricia championnat et que vous
allez retrouver à 23h15 et philippe
labro demain à 12h45 je vous rappelle
l'information essentielle de ce journal
d'information vous avons appris en
milieu d'après midi la mort de l'acteur
français patrick dewaere 35 ans qui
s'est vraisemblablement suicidé voilà à
23h15 donc patricia charnolé reviendra
sur ce suicide pour le plaisir de vous
retrouver quant à moi demain
bonsoir à tous à